[Applause]
[Music]
we will roll on this rehearsal so we can
look at playback Mark we are shooting
the nightmare pool party of all time
happy sunny day but this swimming pool
hides a terrifying secret
hello
my
exactly you often times don't see movies
that feature real inwater camera work
there's so many aspects to underwater
camera work it's very
tricky sh we're leading up to today
involves uh sort of the water
POV the camera is going to rush into his
mouth you have to think think about okay
where are the bubbles traveling what
does the hair do how deep can we get how
long can the actress hold her
breath you rely heavily on signals and
underwater
speakers there's a lot of people that
got to come together to prep for
this it's incredibly sophisticated to do
Marco